india is becoming the new epicenter of
the pandemic the country posted a new
single day
world record reporting more than 332
thousand new covet cases this morning
the actual number is likely to be much
higher
and as lucy kraft reports the country
with the world's second largest
population
is desperate for help toward to ward off
a catastrophe even mass cremations held
at makeshift facilities
can't keep up with the pace of death as
covid cases explode across india
workers say they've never seen anything
like it with even young children among
the victims
families gathered nearby said their
final farewells
nobody helped in time we were running
here and there for a ventilator
she died after the oxygen ran out said
this man whose mother was among the dead
about half of india states are in
lockdown
the country's health care system is
collapsing with widespread shortages of
medicine
oxygen ventilators and hospital beds
said independent journalist smita sharma
i think there's just one way to describe
it right now it's a
living hell india once praised for its
handling of the initial coveted wave
last
year is now being criticized for opening
up too soon
and for mixed messaging prime minister
narendra modi who this week said india
had been hit by a coveted storm
has been rebuked for allowing mass
political rallies to continue
often with lacks antiviral measures
and a traditional hindu bathing festival
the kumaila
was permitted this year drawing millions
of pilgrims
it's now been deemed a super spreader
event dr abhishek rimal said virus
mutations and pandemic fatigue
could make india the world's worst
coveted hot spot in the current pace
if we really do not put a major public
health measure to bring this down
it will definitely become the new
epicenter in days to come
vaccinations are running behind schedule
and even before this current wave peaks
experts are bracing for a third wave
that could further strain the country's
health care system
anthony lucy kraft in tokyo thank you